dalkia bonsoir merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rc france alors de telles
scènes de chaos en plein paris avec des
tirs de mortiers cela interpelle
aujourd'hui car elles ont été filmées
mais est ce que c'est une scène inédite
où effectivement ce type de scène est
fréquente dans le secteur alors c'est
assez fréquent de voir ce genre de
scènes de tirs de mortiers d'artifices
mais c'est plutôt fréquents la nuit là
ce qui est assez inédit c'est que ça se
passe de jour en pleine journée
1 d'abord un vendredi en fin d'après
midi puis samedi en fin d'après-midi à
peu près à la même heure et surtout au
même endroit on est sur le même angle de
rue et donc vous imaginez bien que dans
un quartier comme ça résidentiel à
proximité d'un square à proximité d'une
école
on a beaucoup de beaucoup d'enfants
d'ailleurs sur la première vidéo qui a
été diffusée vendredi
il ya un mortiers d'artifice qui vient
explosé dans un sport où il ya des
enfants et donc vous imaginez un peu si
s'il y avait eu une famille à ce moment
là des enfants une poussette une
personne âgée même si ainsi un tir de
mortier s'était retrouvé dans un
appartement ce qui peut arriver et
provoquer un drame donc malheureusement
c'est fréquent et ce sont des choses qui
qui qui se multiplient alors qu'on ne
sait pas des affrontements au mortier
ces affrontements des rixes de rue à
mains nues ou ou à coups de barre de fer
arme blanche parfois et malheureusement
il ya parfois des règlements de comptes
à l'armé à feu et d'ailleurs dans un
dans une proximité vraiment immédiate de
ce quartier là on est on se situe dans
le bas belleville
vous avez eu 300 mètres plus bas côté
10e arrondissement cette fois ci la nuit
dernière un individu qui a été
grièvement blessé par balles dans un
règlement de compte donc est vraiment
une flambée de des violences dans dans
l'ensemble du nord-est parisien pas
seulement dans le 19e arrondissement
dans l'ensemble des arrondissements du
nord est parisien et moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est vous l'avez mentionné
la la réaction plutôt la non réaction du
maire du 19e qui finalement a considéré
que comme il n'y avait pas de trace un
je cite il n'y avait pas lieu pour lui
de réagir
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui le politique
ne donne pas de réponses à ses habitants
qui sont sans doute terrifié on imagine
au vu de ces images
en tout cas le en tout cas le politique
de
de paris non et le pire dans tout ça
c'est que la ville de paris considère
qu'elle n'a pas de responsabilité en
matière de sécurité
or ce qui est factuellement vrai c'est
qu'elle n'a pas de responsabilité en
matière de police et pouvoir de police
étant intégralement exclusivement
dévolue à la préfecture de police
mais la sécurité ça n'est pas que la
police quand vous êtes maire
d'arrondissement au maire de paris
eh bien vous avez vous avez les moyens
d'agir pour la sécurité générale de d'un
environnement ça passe par la mixité
dans les logements sociaux et arrêter de
ghettoïser systématiquement certains
quartiers en empilant le logement social
sur le logement social
ça passe par la mixité commerciale en
luttant contre la monoactivité ça passe
par la propreté aussi l'entretien de la
voirie
ça passe aussi par l'émission vous
donnez à vos agents de sécurité il ya
trois mille cinq cents agents de la
ville de paris qui sont dédiés à la
sécurité à la surveillance des voies
publiques à la tranquillité publique
or ces agents là sont déployés par parce
que la ville de paris a fait un choix
politique de les déployer sur des sur
des missions qui sont des missions de
verbalisation des véhicules en
stationnement gênant une verbalisation
des terrasses des commerces et des et
des cafés parce que ça rapporte
finalement plus dans l'est dans les
caisses de la ville que de que de que de
faire de l'îlotage et de la surveillance
de la voie publique et donc c'est c'est
peut-être la redéfinition des missions
de ces agents là c'est aussi le
déploiement de la vidéoprotection il ya
une opposition idéologique de la ville
de paris depuis des années pour déployer
la vidéoprotection or les policiers sont
en demande de vidéoprotection parce que
c'est un outil clé à la fois dans le
renseignement dans la surveillance de
ces bandes est aussi évidemment dans
l'élucidation des ddd délits et les
infractions
vous employez le thème d'idéologie
comment est ce que vous comprenez qu
aujourd'hui dans la capitale on en est
arrivé là c'est la faute à qui la faute
à une idéologie pour reprendre votre
terme en tout cas il ya beaucoup de
sectarisme
on peut le voir à la ville de paris mais
vous savez ça fait ça fait 25 ans que la
même équipe dirige cet arrondissement la
du 19e ça fait à peu près
le même temps que leurs amis dirige les
arrondissements du nord est parisien et
ça fait 20 ans que la ville de paris et
dirigé par la même équipe et est très
honnêtement quand on voit un peu ce
refus
ce refus de regarder la réalité en face
alors même qu'on a des images qui font
le tour des réseaux sociaux qui font
qu'ils tournent en boucle comme sur
votre chaîne sur les sur l'ensemble des
chaînes d'info d'information en continu
on a encore des élus qui réfute qui
refusent de voir cette réalité parce
qu'évidemment c'est une réalité qu'il ne
souhaite pas voir qu'il ne souhaite pas
montrer parce que c'est c'est
directement lié à l'heure à leur
inaction et est imputable à leur bilan
et la police sur le terrain que dit elle
elle est désemparée
écoutez pour avoir eu l'occasion de
discuter avec des policiers notamment
avec débat que deux nuits dans le
nord-est parisien
croyez moi que ils font leur travail ils
le font bien et ils le font dans des
conditions difficiles avec les moyens
avec le peu de moyens qu'on leur donne
mais moi je trouve que c'est assez
facile d'incriminer la police or on sait
très bien qu'aujourd'hui si vous voulez
lutter efficacement contre cette petite
délinquance
encore faut-il que lorsqu'ils sont
interpellés ces délinquants ils puissent
être condamnés donc encore faut-il qu'il
y ait une réponse pénale
or aujourd'hui on sait très bien que
malheureusement quand il ya
interpellation bien souvent ces c'est à
ces individus là surtout quand ils sont
mineurs sont relâchés aussitôt ce qui
fait que vous avez un
vous avez un manque total de sanctions
et ça ne peut que conduire
ça ne peut que conduire à la halle a
récidivé en tout cas à ce que ce genre
de pratique continue et je vais vous
donner un autre exemple la préfecture de
police a fait le calcul conscrits oui on
vous écoute bien lisse ya baroin vous et
moi et j'avais j'avais une voix
j'entendais une voix pardon dans mon
ordinateur je disais pardon que la
préfecture de police estime que 60 % des
délits à paris sont causés par vous
savez les fameux mineurs étrangers
isolés
la préfecture de police demandent donc à
la ville de paris puisque c'est une
compétence de la ville de paris elle
demande à la ville de paris de d'évaluer
l'âge de ces individus parce que vous
imaginez bien que beaucoup
deux personnes se déclarent comme étant
mineur pour bénéficier on va dire d'une
protection juridique
or bien souvent ce sont des personnes
qui sont majeurs et qui sont très
largement majeur la ville de paris
refuse de faire ces évaluations là c'est
les compétences départementales l'aide
sociale à l'enfance
elle refuse alors que c'est une demande
de la préfecture de police donc comment
voulez vous que la police fasse
correctement son travail
si derrière que ce soit en terme de
vidéoprotection en termes de soutien aux
policiers par les agents de sécurité
que ce soit en termes de l'environnement
global la ville finalement fait tout
pour mettre des bâtons dans les roues à
la préfecture de police
merci beaucoup pierre lycia d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes ancien élu parisien du xviiie
arrondissement de la capitale